[Musique]
depuis quelques semaines son visage et
son physique font le buzz dans la presse
people nationale
terrance tel bientôt ikon de l'émission
danse avec les stars
mais ce que l'on ignore ici c'est que ce
top model qui défilent sur des podiums
internationaux et martinique
je suis à paris en ce moment je vol pour
los angeles demain mais j'espère
infiniment voir bientôt en martinique
celui qui a participé à son ascension
c'est lui son manager
derrière chaque mannequin qu'il suit sur
la scène internationale il se donne pour
mission de valoriser la martinique
c'est très bien de
rappeler que tu es un fils du pays donc
par son père donc la famille tels en
martinique
donc tu aimes ça a vécu son enfance ici
aujourd'hui
terrance défilent régulièrement sur les
grands podiums internationaux new york
milan mais à paris les critères de
sélection sont différents ce qui
fonctionne énormément
à paris ce sont les gars très très faim
aussi fin que les filles dont s'il était
très très ce qu'ils nient il
fonctionnerait à paris mais le fait
qu'il soit qu'il lègue des pectoraux
qu'il ait des bras et qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient sculpté comme un âge il ne
rentre pas forcément dans les vêtements
donc c'est ça qui le freine sur le
marché parisien alors sa sélection dans
une émission qui rassemble en moyenne 5
millions de téléspectateurs sonne comme
une consécration pour la carrière de
terrain mais pas seulement
le mannequinat grâce avec danse avec les
stars la permettre la mare tient
évidemment une visibilité ailleurs un
jeune parce qu'on a été au souk le socle
de la carrière de tir ans et on l'a
accompagné jusqu'à 7
ce tremplin qui va l'emmener à une étape
supérieure de visibilité de
médiatisation parce que pour perdurer
dans l'industrie également il faut
arriver à ce niveau de people il faut
être un people koi tu nicole en toute
discrétion terrain tu continues à vanter
les beautés de la martinique à travers
le monde et c'est encore sa martinique
qu'il entend valoriser prochainement
dans l'émission danse avec les stars